What guys is not donation reading sorry.
Wait wrong room.
Sorry Wait, give me a sec Okay, we're in the right room now.
Sorry Guys already forgot what what room we were in sorry I
Already forgot what room we're in for these streams guys.
Hello everybody.
Hello, hello So, oh my gosh, it wouldn't be a dorky bird
stream about a little bit of scuff.
I'm so sorry, today's been, okay, not gonna lie.
All right, I'm not, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna like
sugarcoat it.
I won't, I won't like, you know, I won't lie.
Today, today was really rough, I'll say it.
I had a really, really rough day.
today was really rough but the one thing I looked forward to
today though was being able to hang out with you dragoons
because not gonna lie even though I had a really rough day
uh you I always look forward to streaming for you guys
because you guys make it all make it all better and like I
always feel happy whenever I'm streaming for you guys and
it's just I just love like hanging with my dragoons because
you guys always make me so happy and like forget about the
troubles and stuff it's also helps a lot because it's like i
get to like not worry about the stuff that made the day
rough you know it's a little i guess it's a little like a
pause on like the real world shit going outside it's like
you know uh You know, like, oh, if I stream right now, I
don't have, and I keep streaming, I don't have to worry
about what's going on until I stop my stream, and then it's
back to having a rough time.
It's like a symbiotic escapism.
Yeah, yeah.
Maiza, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
sense of donations to read.
No, I read it.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not so dead poor.
Perfect.
Now she won't read this.
Thank you, but the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mike, thank you, the super chat.
Um, yeah, it was just a, it's just a really rough day today.
Um, just a lot of stuff going on, uh, behind the scenes and
stuff.
I think, okay, um, I had like, uh, I think like one of the
reasons why it was like super rough was because like okay
this is a little personal it's a little personal um but like
I did have like a little argument okay maybe it wasn't that
little maybe it wasn't that little but I had an argument um
with my parents about some things um so that's why it was
like super rough and um it's a little bit better now um but
yeah that's why i was like oh i can't wait to just stream
stream because then i can like escape from it and just spend
time with my dragoons it's never fun whenever you argue with
your parents it's never a fun time because you're just like
no and you're like yeah and they're like
And I'm like, I'm going to my room.
And then, you know, like, you go to your room and you're
like, and then you refuse to go out your room because when
you go out your room, they win.
You know, you know, when you have those types of arguments
and then you're like, oh, I want to.
I didn't I have not went out of my room yet, but then
eventually you have to eventually go out of your room and
then you and your parents pretend nothing happened You know,
and then when you finally and then oh yeah, you have to come
out to either eat or use the bathroom And then when you
finally do come out of your room you pretend nothing
happened never had that argument in the first place and it's
like the awkward silence and then they'll be like what do
you want to eat and then you're just like i don't care and
then and then the next day everything will just be fine um
you know think of the super chat thank you thank you i'll
have a better day tomorrow thank you thank you thank you
thank you um of course yeah me too i obviously i hope i do
have a better day tomorrow uh james thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you d dragon thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you the feeling is mutual dokiest
dreams always share my week of the troubles thank you to the
super chat thank you thank you yeah the social research just
just parents things that's why that's why you should never
have kids unless your kids subscribe to me
anyway that's why you should never have kids unless those
kids will become dokey bird subscribers then that's fine um
but other than that because then you know when you have kids
that's gonna happen to you too where you're gonna have those
exact same arguments and then you'll realize oh my god my
parents were right i was a piece of shit but for now i want
to think that i'm right for now i want to think that i'm
right and the knowledge of what it's like to be a parent to
realize wow my fucking kid is a piece of shit
i do not want to enforce the circle of life right now i like
to live with the ignorance that i am the perfect child uh
cheer thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm
glad that streaming hang out with the the dragoons helps you
get away from the stress uh thank you super chat thank you
thank you i quit the cycle
um uh but yeah i hope the music isn't too loud guys uh i
hope the lo-fi is comfy um i really like doing these uh i
know this is like only my second stream on the late night
radio the late night radio shows but i'm honestly already
starting to really enjoy it because It's just a nice time to
just hang out, like be real with you guys, just talking and
having a conversation with my dragoons.
And it's always a nice time.
And I hope that it helps with your sleep or it's a nice,
like, it's a nice, like, good morning for those people on
the other side of the world.
I can up the music a little bit if people can't hear it.
I hear some people are like, what music?
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Screw YouTube for kids.
Subscribe to Dokey Bird for all your childhood.
Extracting entertainment.
Yes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you have a child and they are becoming an iPad kid,
please make them subscribe to dokeybird You might as well
like dirty dirty fucked mentally because they're becoming
iPad kids if you guys don't know like Okay, no matter what
my content will always be better than cocoa melon because
apparently I've talked about this before but Coco Melon and
like a lot of like kids channels are known to actually harm
your child's brain development so no matter what I cannot be
worse than that at best they will learn some profanity but
they were going to learn it eventually so you might as well
start them off young like you don't want them to suddenly
learn it from their friends because like if their friend can
send means their friends are bad influences but if they
learn from me at least you know it's not because of a bad
influence it's because it's just so natural in my vocabulary
that it's just part of how I speak because like you don't
want your child to learn fuck from their friends because
like what would the context be but then you know if your
child learns fucking fucking from me it's just part of an
expression it just means like a lot of something so it's not
part of whatever context whatever bad influence that their
friends are doing to your child you know for me i'm a good
influence because even though i'm stupid um even though I'm
stupid.
I'm not influencing.
I'm not like...
I'm not fucking with your child's development.
10 minutes past.
I should be okay, I think.
He did the swears.
That's nine minutes.
Thank you for the super chat, Jonathan.
Thank you, thank you.
Go ahead and thank you for the super chat.
You're seven years late on that tip.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lilith, thank you for the super chat.
you.
Yeah, as a parent, I'm thankful that the realization that
used to be a rude dumb fuck happened before I had a kid.
Now I'm mostly a nice dumb fuck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, all I'm saying is that if you have children, please
make sure to have them subscribe to Doki Bird so I can get a
million subscribers before I don't I honestly at this I
don't think I'm gonna get millions of subscribers before the
end of the year unless I hit the algorithm hard I I don't
think it's possible
But I'm looking at like I actually calculated the cuz like
okay The reason why you guys must be like wow dokey Why are
you calculating when you're gonna hit a million subscribers?
It's cuz like at a million I want to make a huge I'm
planning a huge project for a million but the thing is I
need to know when I hit a million so I can debut this so I
can pinpoint the timing of the project for a million
subscribers I haven't started the plans for a million but I
need to know when will I hit it so I can calculate how many
months of planning I need to do for a project for a million
subscribers like so so that's why like I'm trying to I need
to know exactly because it's like oh my gosh if I like you
know if I like plan it advance like way to advance and I
have it done by before I hit a million but then like so many
things happen afterwards and I hold on to this project on
standby for like I don't know half a year after it's
completed, then it'll be outdated.
I don't want something to be outdated.
So, like, that's why I'm trying to, like, I always, like,
try to figure out when I hit.
It's also, like, subscriber milestones, too.
I'm trying to, like, figure out, I think, like, at 800K
subscribers, there's something I want to do.
I hate 800K subscribers.
But, like, I also, I'm also worried that it would take too
long.
I'm a little worried that it's gonna take a little bit too
long And now I'm like, oh, it's gonna be so outdated But
it's gonna Like I would be like so impatient Because I would
rather just debut the project That I had planned for 800k
earlier Then just waiting for 800k Um, it's just like wait
I'm just like impatient too I'm very impatient on things
Case in point, like, uh, there's, like, things I, um,
there's, like, things I want, I told you guys, there's
things I watch, and there's things, like, that I, like,
like, maybe I don't play a particular game or something, but
I, like, want to know the ending of something.
Oh, yeah, if I play a game, this is very, very rare.
Okay, not JK, I lie.
There's not the stream ones, not the stream games.
Okay, guys, I need you guys to know this, but there's a game
I haven't really played, or, Or I haven't really played or
like I'm not looking interested in playing.
But I want to know like the plot or story of the game.
I will actually look up the ending.
Because like I know I won't play it.
Like I know I won't play the game.
So like I'd be like oh I want to know like how the look.
It's like JRPGs.
I know I won't play JRPG games.
that like I'm curious about like I'll be like oh um what's
gonna happen like what's what's the story and stuff like
that so I just like look it up and I'll be like oh okay but
like JRPGs is such a terrible example for me because it's so
fucking long that you get sucked into a rabbit hole I think
that I only done that for like one JRPG and it was for uh no
two it was the one with the character and the other one was
like one of the personas because like i remember like i quit
playing the lightning one because it was terrible uh like
there's nothing else i can really say other than you know it
was pretty bad like i played up until um i played up until
like i think like I played like one to two hours and then I
was like okay yeah like I that this is not for me because
like I remember telling you guys like oh these were the
JRPGs I played like final like because you guys were like
have you ever played Final Fantasy and I was like yes
there's only been two Final Fantasy that I've played and
touched and like apparently both Final Fantasy games I've
tried to play were one of the worst installments in Final
Fantasy but they were literally the two I would be like,
let's give Final Fantasy a shot.
And then one of them was the one with the three girls.
I don't remember their names.
The one of the three girls that were the main characters.
And apparently that was supposed to be a sequel to the game
before, to the last Final Fantasy game.
But I played that.
Yeah, X2.
That was my very first Final Fantasy game.
And then I tried to play it.
And I was like, I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Because it's a sequel.
But I didn't realize it was a sequel.
I had, I was very young as well.
So I really had like no clue it was a sequel.
But I was like, I remember like going to like EB games.
And then like, for those who don't know what EB games, it's
like EA games.
But like B for Canadian.
Anyway, anyway.
I, and then I saw that I was like, I was like, Dad, I want
to buy this because Final Fantasy, it's everywhere.
And then, uh, and then, and then, you know, I tried it,
didn't know what the fuck is going on.
I think it's also because when I was young, when I was
younger, I was mega illiterate versus now, which is like
illiteracy by choice.
Back then, it was because I was just really stupid.
sort of illiterate and I like didn't really know how to read
but now it's by choice that I don't read and anyway um
anyway um and then a couple of years passed by like a
hundred years passed by oh my god Doki how old are you a
hundred years past it felt like a hundred years and then the
That's the lightning game came out and I was like, let me
give it another shot.
Maybe like, you know, I, I would, it would, maybe it was
just the game and it wasn't me, you know, maybe like, you
know, little, or like little dokey just back then little
dokey just wasn't into JRPGs.
And now slightly older dokey will be okay with it because
I'm more mature and like possibly I could read a little
better.
um and possibly the more mature you are and by the way tick
tock hasn't been invented yet nor has vine been invented yet
so like my attention span is still decent uh so so like i
haven't got like fucked over by like the lack of an
attention span because none of the short form content
existed yet it was like long form content meta still so like
it was still let's play meta where people will watch like
like one hour let's play videos because the 10 minute shit
hasn't hit yet um anyway uh so i was like all right the file
that fantasy 13 came out so i was like all right let's oh my
god lightning oh i saw an advertisement on about her where
she like modeled some louis vuitton haunt bags and she was
like a model and everything oh my god it can't be that bad
anyway so i tried i tried file fantasy 13 and i was and then
obviously we all know the reputation of file fantasy 13.
but at that time i was like maybe it's just me you know
maybe I was like I didn't know it was considered bad bad
because like also at that time I didn't really look at
reviews I was just like it was just like experience wise so
I stopped after I think like after like two like one to two
hours I stopped and I was like oh man Final Fantasy just
sucks for me I just I just I just I was like, oh man, Final
Fantasy, maybe it just sucks.
And then after that, I never touched, I think like after
that, I never like touched JRPGs again.
Oh no, that's a lie.
I try to play Persona as well.
And then I realized, I think like after I played Persona and
I try to play the Persona, the one that came out.
On the PlayStation
And then After Okay but like what are the odds That would
play two of the One two of the worst Like games In the
franchise Like what were the fucking odds That that would be
me
It's like Similar It's like similar to how I told you guys
for some fucking reason I was I managed to watch Two Cirque
I've only been to two Cirque de Soleil shows and for some
fucking reason I managed to to watch the same show Twice
from Cirque de Soleil How there was a 15 plus year gap
between two both of those shows But it happened to be the
same show I couldn't believe it but those who didn't hear
this story I told this story on the stream I think with with
with Gumi and what happened was that when I was really young
I went to see a Cirque du Soleil show and it was this show I
remember it very well because I bought the soundtrack of it
I bought the soundtrack of the show and so I was like oh
shit hell yeah I fucking listened to that on my fucking
iPhone very regularly it was in my iTunes and my iPhone so I
like remember the song so well because it was like 15 plus
years of listening to that song to those songs when they
play on shuffle and then like 15 plus years later I realized
oh my god maybe like not even 15 i could i swear it could be
longer it could be 20 years honestly i will not be oh my
gosh i don't even know how long and i need you guys to know
how many shows cirque du soleil has okay cirque i'm gonna
look it up right now cirque du soleil that shit pissed me
off so much i i couldn't believe it because like we i bought
vip like i bought like front row seats for the second one
just to re-wash the same thing.
Blade Wing, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for some fucking reason.
You happen to be the best VTuber in the world, and I can't
fucking believe it, so keep doing what you do forever.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate that you think that way of me.
Alright, no, I need to look.
I need to tell you guys, because I looked it up.
I couldn't believe it.
I actually looked this up because I was like, I I couldn't
fucking believe that I managed to re-watch this fucking
show.
Like, I couldn't fucking believe it.
I, like, counted, too.
I was like, how many shows have they done?
And they've done, like, I remember counting it.
I, like, looked up on the Wikipedia and literally counted
how many shows they've done.
They've done.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
11, 12, 30, 40, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25,
26, 27, 28, 29, 31, 32, 33, 44, 45, 36, 37, 38, 49, 40, 41,
42, 43, 44, 45, 46, 48, 48, they've done 53 different shows!
And I somehow managed to watch the same one twice!
It pissed me off.
Okay, anyway, as I was saying, so, yeah, so I bought, like,
I was like, oh, my God, I haven't seen Cirque du Soleil in
so fucking long, like, modern times.
So I was like, oh, shit, I'm gonna go watch Cirque du Soleil
because, obviously, I would think it'd be a new show if it's
touring again.
again they always they tour so much and they always come up
with new things so how the fuck was i supposed to know that
they will redo the same thing 15 year 15 to 20 years ago
anyway so yeah i remember i paid for the the one of the more
really expensive tickets because i wanted to be at the front
at the front because i hate sitting in the back because like
my eyes aren't as good as last okay not okay it might not
look like i'm wearing glasses right now but like when i wash
things i wear my glasses like yeah like oh i can still see
it but like i like seeing their like i could like seeing
their expressions and their faces because usually there's no
second or third screen because it's a circus if you guys
don't know for the yeah i paid for a fucking rerun like for
Cirque du Soleil they don't have like additional screens
where you can where zoom in on the faces and stuff like you
it's just like if you sit in the back it's just little
fucking stick figures so i didn't want to see that i was
like i really want like like experience the circus and like
experience like what they're what they're feeling when
they're performing and so i was like i ain't buying the back
seats i'm buying the front seats uh because i don't want to
see fucking stick figures trying to perform stuff because
it's not as impressive when they're so far TV because at
least a TV or DVD or the YouTube video has like close-ups
like I okay this is my opinion but like I rather just watch
if I'm going to watch something live I rather have watch it
like in the front rather than the back unless it's like a
huge concert thing I don't know I think like concerts that's
sort of different because for con performances it's a
different story but like concerts I'm fine with concerts if
I'm sitting in that back because it's all about the music
and like there's usually like screens where it'll close ups
and stuff of the performances but if it's like musicals
entertainment circuses stuff like that they usually don't
have an extra screen where you can like see what's going on
close up so like if I if I rather just sit in the front
where I can see what the fuck is going on then the back
because if I can't do that I might as well just watch the
thing on TV or like watch it on YouTube
Anyway So yeah I bought I got this in the front And I heard
the first song I heard the I even bought like overpriced
pretzels and Coke too I even spent money on overpriced
Concert food And Because that pretzel was so fucking dry was
like 15 canadian dollars so for you americans it's like five
dollars
so you americans out there it's like nothing for you guys
but for us it's like 15 canadian
anyway i i bought a fucking like i bought an overpriced dry
as fuck uh pretzel and uh and and an overpriced bottle of
coke just so watch a rerun and i was so fucking mad
like i heard the first song and i was like wait i know this
song why do i know this song it's like i i was like i was
like in denial at first i was like coping and being like why
do i I know this song.
There's no way I know this song.
And then after like the first 30 seconds, I was like, oh my
god, no, no.
So, so yeah, when I was in denial and then I was like
bargaining and then anger.
I'm sort of still like in, I'm still sort of like going
through the five stages of grief at the moment.
It's been months, but I'm still going through the five
stages of grief by the way.
I I felt so betrayed chat I felt so fucking betrayed um but
yes I feel like I'm just a very unlucky person sometimes I
feel like okay I'm either like of I'm either I'm so I'm I no
I know I am very unlucky I'm incredibly unlucky person and a
few times I'm like lucky is because I like
I would I get something or like if something good happens to
me is because I work so hard that it counteracts my
unluckiness I feel
um Hanta thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
have you ever thought you're really really clumsy like
that's a talent in the worst ways man thank you for the
super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Delta, thank you for the super chat.
Some locations across the world do specific shows only.
No, no.
The Cirque du Soleil I've seen were the touring ones.
That's the worst part.
Like coincidentally, all the Cirque du Soleil, like the two
Cirque du Soleil shows I watched were the ones that they
decided to tour in my city.
And that was the worst part.
Yeah.
Just the touring shows So 15 years The touring show is this
Yeah the 50 to 20 years They decided to tour again Anyway
Delta Oh yeah I said that Mario thank you Super Chat Thank
you Thank you If we watch something twice Are we then The
blooms Thank you for the Super Chat Thank you Thank you uh
yeah i don't think i'll ever be able to see a new circus
today i would now now i'm afraid because i don't remember
the name of the show i watched that's the worst part is that
i actually don't remember the show that i watched and i feel
like if i try to watch circus delay again for the third
fucking time i'm gonna just pay i'm gonna i will not be
surprised if it's the third time
mock me welcome to the welcome back to tomato farm welcome
back that's a me problem um let's see uh uh but yeah anyway
that's what i'm saying like uh oh my gosh how did i get to
this fucking tangent oh yeah it's because of my uh it's
because of how unlucky i was for for jrpgs i managed to
somehow choose two of the worst installments in the
franchise oh my god anyway i don't know you guys know this i
tweeted this out uh i tweeted this out but like um there was
like major fucking leaks in the animation uh in the
animation sector so for those who don't know i really really
love animation and like animated shows um i i i watched a
lot of them over the years because i honestly um especially
because like for drama stuff for drama shows i cannot do
like live action drama shows quite well because i just get
so depressed and i get i get so depressed and like I'm
already you know I'm already having a rough time I it's why
like I said this before but I normally watch like comedies
animation or like just things that are like super
light-hearted and I tend to avoid drama stuff or and like I
usually avoid like gore and things like I actually I hate
the gore and invincible I I hate it so much but like I
understand like in the show like it needs that but like i
always look away when the gore is coming in for invincible
because i can't handle that stuff like i actually look away
and like um and wait until it's over uh because like i'm
like bro life is already very depressing and i don't i i
don't need more of that um and like oh my okay also I I
don't understand people who complain the thing is okay you
guys don't know this but for those like some people might
not know is I actually read the invincible comics um and I
didn't finish reading it I think I read like I read the
ending of the comics for invincible and I read like um I
think like a couple of chapters in the beginning of
invincible but uh um anyway uh and like I know like the
major plot points in the comics too so like I know like
what's But anyway, apparently people who like read the
invincible comics, they were complaining about how little
the gore was.
I was like, are you fucking kidding?
They were like, you guys toned it down so much.
And I'm like, what?
What do you mean?
I was just like, you what?
more but if we had more the fucking ratings for that show
would be like like r18 at that point wait is it invincible
okay what what is invincible rating invincible rating uh
ratings for uh what is it parental rating i don't even know
what it's called oh it's mature yeah that's not even r18
it's mature but like i'm pretty sure if we go further it
would have been like heart heart it would have been like
r-a-t i was like there it was already too much for me and
like they added moments in there they added in their
thousand i was like what the fuck um yeah they said like the
people were complaining the like hardcore comic readers were
complaining that like they didn't go like hard enough I was
just like, are you what?
What do you I?
I was like, bro, I wish they toned it down I was like, bro,
I what do you mean?
It was like, oh my, I like, like, bro, I, like, bro,
sometimes I want to eat when I watch this show like
Sometimes, sometimes I want, yeah, but like M for mature is,
isn't M for mature, like less than R18?
Because like R18 is like a different, isn't it go like, uh,
um, what was it, what parental rating guide?
Okay, I need to look at the parental rating guide.
I'm pretty sure 18 is the top and then mature is below that.
That's for video games.
There's different rating guides.
Bro, I can't keep up with this.
Like,
why can't it be universal?
I don't understand.
I, like, why can't just things be universal?
Just like how English is like one of the universal
languages.
We don't want like English too.
Oh wait, British is English too.
And that is why the British aren't the universal English.
this is why this is why we don't acknowledge british english
and every time we're like how do you spell this okay that's
not true because is it fucked up for me to say that like
that's not true because the uk has uk has sort of forced a
lot of other countries to adopt the way of spelling in the
uk like color like okay like in canada we spell color with
c-o-l-o-u-r But I feel like we've sort of stopped doing that
because people make fun of us like the Americans make fun of
us whenever we do spell color that way
Whenever we we spell it that way because I don't spell it
like that anymore I've like assimilated into like Into like
mainstream universal England And I feel like the Americans
are wrong Why the fuck is there different?
There is, there's video games, movies, television, music,
comedy.
There's, what?
There's a max rate.
Okay, that's funny.
In comic books, instead of like mature, it's max, like for
explicit content.
That's pretty.
Okay, that's, that's funny that they don't even say mature.
It's like max com, max explicit content.
okay okay so in video games it's adults only with the a it's
mature and then a for adults only and then for a television
that it's mature audience oh okay no okay so the highest is
mature in television in movies it's restricted r and then nc
17.
oh may include violence sex behaviors or any other elements
that most parents would consider too mature for viewing by
their children.
Alright, that's good to know.
I wish it was universal because it makes it so much more
complicated.
Yeah, that's just way too complicated in my opinion.
I'd rather just be a universal thing because like, we
already have so many things to worry about,
We already have a lot of things.
Anyway, what was I saying?
How do I fucking how did I get to this topic oh my gosh
where was I oh no my tangents have its own tangents now
we're we're in too deep we're in too deep oh yeah animation
sorry I was supposed I was talking about animation so
recently there there has been a giant animation leak uh
where uh who I don't know some fucking insider in Disney
basically leaked a lot of pilots a lot of scripts a lot of
like pitch Bibles and a lot of like canceled show episodes
um uh on like anonymous forums and it was okay I read the
story behind it was so funny so I think like one of the main
discoverers was like some gravity falls fan that was like oh
my god guys somebody leaked everything on like twit like
they're like talking about it on twitter and then people
were like what what's going on and i was like reading the
story because i was like what how did all this got leaked so
apparently there was a thread and it was on anonymous forum
and it was a thread that was like um Oh my god, here's a
leak And then some other guy was like That's a shitty leak
Anyway, look here are all these other shows These other
shows that are so much better Than this leak that I'm
leaking That's so fucking funny Cause they're like They're
like Fuck that leak, that's a shitty one Let me show you a
good leak And then he proceeded to link He proceeded to link
like link all like a bunch of like unerred episodes And then
later on he was like even better here's some more links I
was like what
My god and then and then he was like he just started
Non-stop like there was like a leak war being like who has
the better Disney leak and it was all like Disney centric
because like the the the thread started talking about like a
dis like an unaired Disney pilot and and and then obviously
Twitter found out and was like oh my god these like Twitter
like um TV show stands found out and like especially Gravity
Falls because that fucking fandom is very um it's like it's
the fact that it's still two seasons if you guys didn't know
gravity falls technically only had two seasons and it it
ended let's see how long ago how long did gravity falls end
it ended in what wait what oh my god okay it ended on 23rd
okay 2016 oh my gosh is it 2016 yeah it ended on like 2016
really oh my god i need to like double check my information
at that point end of 2016.
oh my god
eight years and the fandom is still going incredibly strong
and like i'm not surprised that it was like a gravity falls
fan on twitter that made it like that brought the Tension of
it and then so then this another so then like people started
Compiling everything that came from that thread and They
were like freaking out and was like oh my anyway So I like
looked at the I looked at the there's like a folder with all
of it And I was so sad because okay, it was actually so
interesting because it talks about like people pitching
their ideas For Disney pilots for like Disney animated
pilots and stuff and there was like For different people
That tried to make DuckTales.
I thought that was so interesting.
Four different Animators, like four different Showrunners
try to Pitch their own version Of DuckTales.
And I actually I was like reading all four of them, and the
one That we got was the most interesting.
It was actually like, if you read the Pitch Bible, it was
actually Like the most interesting One and most creative
one.
out of the four um because like i think like two of them was
just based off of the original show and like it was just
like being like continuation of the original show i don't
remember the third one was also sort of creative but the the
one they picked that became ducktails the pitch bible was
like really creative and actually like put their own spin
because it wasn't just a lot of the DuckTales one was just
like a sketch and then words and then like a huge blurb of
words and being like blah blah blah this show is gonna start
out as blah blah blah blah blah but then the the one that
became the DuckTales reboot that we got was like an actual
comic I was like oh majority pictures I like that as
somebody that doesn't like to read
This catches my attention.
It's mostly visual.
Niji Night.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I pooped a nose and now I go to sleep.
Work on Sunday is always exciting.
Hope you had nothing but fun and good times with chat.
Bye bye.
Also, I feel old because the PS2 is 24 years old this year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
The PS2 has graduated university and is trying to look for
its first job.
okay but it was actually interesting it was so interesting
because they got really they got really creative with their
pitch bible anyway within the leaks it was also like there
was also like darkwing duck as well and um and uh there was
also like darkwing duck and it was also like saying like
because it was going to be a re um it was going to be like a
reboot of darkwing duck and it was going to be like a
spiritual it was going to like follow up from ducktails but
apparently that got shelved and canceled if you guys didn't
know i was tweeting about it also but like disney animation
is known to only make three seasons because like for them
analytic wise and research wise uh when they three seasons
is like the maximum they disney will usually go in terms of
like financing That by season four, they are really scared
that season four will lose money.
And three seasons to them, they think is the optimal
lifespan for any animated show.
Because it's like, they don't want to go to four.
Because they don't think they make profit.
Neb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You call that a leak.
This is a leak.
Yeah, and like, okay, the thing I don't understand is that a
lot of the, okay, the thing is, it really sucks too, because
a lot of these shows, they do really well with like tweens
and up, I'll say.
Kids don't like these shows.
You can say like kids are not like a super huge fan of like
the shows that we considered we would like.
Like Gravity Falls was really good.
I really like Gravity Falls.
I really like the Owl House.
um i really liked um star versus the forces of evil uh but
we don't talk about the last season okay apparently people
blame star versus the forces of evil last season four as the
one the main reasons why they don't do season four anymore
they're one of the reasons why they don't do season four
because uh stars versus the forces of got a season four and
like they lost a lot of money so so it like backed up
disney's ideas of like we never do a season four because
look at what they did
like look at what they did in season four do you want your
show to be like that so they and uh someone might i remember
like when i tweeted us i was like oh it wasn't canceled They
never had a plan to do season four.
They actually did.
It's just that it was super common knowledge for the
animation team, like in Disney, to know that, uh, to know
that, uh, most shows tend to not get a season four, that
they had, like, a backup plan.
Because, like, they had a backup plan to being like, okay,
if we don't get renewed, uh, if we don't get renewed, then,
like, this is how we're going to end it.
nude like this is always gonna be how we're gonna end this
show and it felt like i honestly felt it was super rushed
too and um and uh and even then the animation team was like
oh yeah like if we had more seasons i would want to do this
i would like love to do that and then they were planning on
having a season four and then uh duck tails and then having
and after season four is over that's when they end it and
then they'll do dark wing duck but they never did that
because disney was But the main reason is that they don't
make merch.
That's what pisses me off the most.
The only reason why Teen Titans Go has like 500,000 seasons
is that they spam so much fucking merch for Teen Titans Go.
None of these other Disney shows make merch.
I like that's what pisses me off because they're like, we
don't get it enough.
support for oh yeah an infinity train i'll fucking love
infinity train they're like we don't you're the shows you
love that you want us to make another season we don't get
enough uh we don't get enough profit from that because
nobody's buying anything buy what what do you want us to buy
the fucking one dollar comic book
like where I'll go to a toy store as teen titans go where
the fuck is the outhouse buy the thing you don't make
exactly There's like there's like it's always merch but what
merch like what do we buy There's so much but but then
they're like oh Uh, but then they're like oh, but if we make
the merch no one's going to buy it because our data shows
that like there it's just a lot loss of profit if we do make
that merch what data what fucking data if you don't make any
what data do you have What do I make?
Yeah.
Anyway.
It's crazy.
But they're willing to make the 500 fucking lightsaber for
Star Wars.
Yeah.
It's just...
Oh, man.
That's why I'm so sad.
Whenever shows get canceled.
Like, get, like, not renewed.
or cat like it shows i enjoy i really miss ducktails woohoo
but uh but um but uh ducktails woohoo yeah um they made
merch for graph barely like it wasn't like they barely did
made merch for gravity falls okay gravity uh falls you see
more shit for fucking teen titans goading dude was over
though but like i feel like there it did not exist as much
as like the other stuff going on there like especially like
a lot of merch they made for gravity falls was not geared
towards children they were clearly geared towards like
millennials like that's the issue they're like if this merch
does not sell for children there's no point in selling
anything and because of that There's no point in there's
this show does not make any profit
That's their data if they're fucking chose if the merch
doesn't sell enough for children They're like it's not
profitable I still buy toys Disney but yeah when a company
is run by like 60 year old grandpa's who sometimes who some
of them still think animation is for children they just be
like it's not profitable because kids don't want to buy it
have you seen a kingdom hearts pile episode for disney's
channel it's on youtube moose thank you the super chat thank
you thank you i don't remember i think i have but um i think
i have but like i'm pretty sure i don't remember much of it
But I've also saw the, what is it, the Sailor Moon American
Sailor Moon cartoon.
And that one was a little silly too.
I think the American Sailor Moon cartoon was also a little
silly.
So I'm glad that they just brought over the Japanese Sailor
Moon over.
Doug, thank you for the super chatting thing.
you too fair we rather have three seasons than 13.
they tend to become a shell their former self so long as
they go on thank you that's super chat thank you thank you
that is true but like if there's still more of the story to
tell i don't see why like if the writers have more of
stories they want to tell and like i think it's different
when the show itself is not like it's not like a serialized
show where like um where the reason why a lot of shows don't
have any progression that's different a lot of like the
actual good animated shows um will have like a progression
of storyline and like where characters age um because like a
lot of them don't go like there's no it's very uncommon for
reruns to go that's why like a lot of like uh shows tend to
have characters that just do not grow up for animation
because they can put reruns of that forever and ever so
and uh and uh because there's no like progression they can
just put random episodes for a rerun and stuff it's why like
the simpsons and like family guy and stuff they're all
fucking the same age forever they never age up because so
they can just put random simpsons episodes or random family
guy episodes because there's no like character progression
for anybody or like character development for anybody
they're just the same person but like what if this happens
and they're like what if that happens um i'm so moderately
bitter about where they ended the original team ties they're
never gonna bring it back because to them it's not
profitable because they're like whoa who bought the merch
what they never made merch until team titans go like what
the do you mean like like the only started making actual
shit for teen titans the moment teen titans go drop like
what do you mean
um anyway yeah og teen titans is amazing but it's they're
never gonna bring it back because children like teen titans
go more like it's just more appealing to watch for little
kids like, I talked about this before.
I feel like, sorry, every time I talk about animation, I go
in a long ass tangent, but like this is one of my favorite
memes about Teen Titans Go.
Like, okay, schedule.
Let me see if I can find it.
I'll show it.
I, oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
This is one of my favorite, this is one of my favorite memes
about Teen Titans Go.
But this is, I showed this.
I talked about this before, but this is how profitable Teen
Titans Go was.
Like,
this was, this was the Teen Titans Go schedule.
It's like Teen Titans Go, Teen Titans Go, Teen Titans Go.
And then he gives a shout, whoa, Teen Titans Go Island
Adventure.
Oh my, and then there are two episodes of good for them good
good for them for putting that two episodes
like oh my god wow they gave steven universe a fucking bone
put two episodes at 7 30 p.m you know what it's good that
they try to diverse a little bit you know um peter thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you uh could be worse
Batman Beyond didn't get comics until a decade later the
live action movie was also canned in the 2000s think of a
super chat think they they also can the animated movie
that's gonna be in the same style as like uh cost of the
spider-verse one too uh yeah they were they also canceled
that if you guys don't remember because it was totally it
was just they just didn't think it would be profitable uh oh
yeah no name thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you two episodes of steven universe before steven years goes
on highest yen thoughts on codename kids next door so sad
that they never made that sequel i remembered when the
creator of codenames kids next door made a whole fucking
what's that word called for like um what's that word when
they do like a whole like online puzzle game oh what's that
word called there's a special word for it uh what's it
called when it's like it's online arg yeah uh arg so like if
you guys didn't know the creator i was there for it because
i was also like super into i i wasn't still am super into
kid i mean i don't know if still am is like the right word
to say but i still miss it but um the creator uh for the
galactic next door which was considered a sequel to the kids
next door and like a lot of like the original voice actors
and the um and like the crew were willing to come back to it
and he made a whole arg to get like fan support uh to to get
fan support to try and like persuade the executives at
cartoon network to like greenlit like a sequel and like when
you saw the arg it pilot, I guess like the pilot episode or
something for the Galactic Next Door.
And it was so cool because I was doing the AIG with
everybody too.
And I was like super hyped for it.
But nothing happened!
Nothing happened.
Does Kids Next Door even have merch?
Obviously it doesn't because why don't we don't have a
sequel?
But at least it went more longer than three seasons.
At least we got six seasons of that.
But I would have loved to have the Galactic Kids Next Door.
I felt like that was like a missed opportunity.
um if they do it now they're just gonna be like banking on
nostalgia and like it's not gonna be the same it's just
gonna be flash animated and i don't want that i think i feel
like i feel like it's gonna it's gonna feel like so
different like i feel like it's gonna be it's just gonna
feel weird um like i i it's just gonna feel like super weird
i feel like the i feel like the budget wouldn't be the same.
It's like when like, what is it?
Okay.
It's like like Flash can be good.
Flash animation can be good, but I feel like after a long
time, um, I mean like, obviously, oh wait, Flash is dead.
What's the newest one?
Um, but like, it can be good because like My Little Pony was
done on, uh, was it done on Flash?
No, what's the, what was he, what was the program they used?
But like, if you guys didn't know, the friendship is messed
magic episodes oh my god the budget for that shit was insane
oh yeah tune boon oh yeah tune boon um but okay uh budget
per episode it got really i was like reading up the budget
budget for each one six million what okay uh okay um what
okay it's like How much is it?
How much is that budget?
Budget for...
What was that budget?
Okay.
It was like $200,000 to $300,000 per episode.
So each season would be like around $6,000.
Like, it was like, yeah, it was like $200,000 to $300,000
per episode.
But like, if you see how the production ran for that, you'd
understand it.
And then after...
yeah it was per episode merch fucking sold a lot though at
least anyway um anyway uh i read that like uh and then like
and then they try to like make a sequel for it but oh my god
the the the quality
like the the quality the quality of that the sequel was wow
wow we i was like looking at the animation quality i was
like wow we that anime that's definitely not 200 to 300 000
per episodes anymore whoa anyway that's how i feel i feel
like if i felt like if we did if we do a sequel to kids next
door now the quality for that So it's like those who were so
hyped about Mega Man and People were so hyped because we're
like Mega Man's gonna get a secret and a show Okay, not Mega
Man.
Mega Man.
Sorry Mega Man.
Mega Man is gonna get a secret Movie and a show and everyone
was so hyped and people found out Will Ferro wasn't gonna
reprise this role as Mega Man And then that's when we all
know things are not gonna be as good as it seems and then
the trailer dropped and then that's when everybody really
knew oh it's that type of sequel and and that's why i hope
that galactic kids next door stays fucking dead because i
feel like it's gonna be very similar
I could feel that if you wait too long if you wait too long
But like not long enough I feel like if you wait Too long
but not long enough The sequel will be really bad But if you
wait really long Really really long that like It's like some
fucking 90s 80s shit that you're rebooting Then it'll be
okay Because then like those people who reboot something uh
that long they want to make sure they take really good care
of the image of that like the reimagining of it but like i
heard the new x-men animated show was like pretty decent too
um yeah is it x-men there's a new x-men show that seems to
uh that's like really good animation wise and uh i haven't
watched it yet but i heard the new x-men animated show was
like animation-wise, was really good.
I haven't watched it yet.
Um, I really love, I love the animated X-Men.
Not the, not the OG animated X-Men.
The one where they were like, fucking kid, like, not sorry,
where they were teenagers.
Okay, they were always teenagers.
But the one where they were like, it was like high school
drama, you know?
Where they were like, one was it watch x-men was that the
one where they was like high school drama almost every
episode i was like x-men evolution yes yes i loved x-men
evolution that was that slaps um i love x-men evolution but
i think the funniest thing they did with uh the funniest
thing about the the new X-Men show is that they changed okay
what's his name they fuck what was his name okay X-Men 97
characters they like change people's powers because they're
like oh this is actually what it's like and I thought it was
so funny
Cyclops I don't know why I forgot Cyclops.
I'm sorry, my brain isn't working.
So Cyclops powers now.
So like, if you guys didn't know, it was so funny.
When I read the explanation, when I read the explanation for
Cyclops powers now, so like, you know how like we all know
it's laser eyes, right?
So like the reason why?
So we all know it's like laser eyes, like the normies, i.e.
me, or like laser eyes.
Yeah.
beams it shoots lasers but now modern wise it's kinetic
blast and now you guys are thinking oh doki what do you mean
by kinetic blast apparently his eyes are portals to the
fucking punch universe and the punch dimension and i and his
eyes pull out these punch lasers from a opens his eyes the
lasers punches you and it's like a fist so they're not
actual like laser beams like you know super mad lasers it's
like a punch laser but like the normies always thought they
were you know super mad lasers and it's through this ad new
ad because there someone posted a
I am not, it's called the punch dimension.
His eyes are portals to the punch dimension so that when he
opens his eyes, he's punching people with his eye lasers.
I thought this was the dumbest thing I've ever read, but it
was also pretty funny.
Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Does Velma count as a reboot a series of Scoop?
We don't talk about Velma.
Do not hate watch Velma.
No, Matt, please, I beg of you, stop hate-watching things,
because the moment you start hate-watching things, you're
gonna give it attention and a reboot, or not reboot, a
renewal of a series.
Please don't.
We don't need another season of Velma.
Please stop hate-watching.
The only reason why Velma got another season is because we
all hate-watched it.
Oh my god.
suck the most is that the animation quality for Velma is
actually pretty good.
That's the worst part.
Like, I actually really like the animation budget for this.
Because they actually go hard on, like...
Guys, you know why I say stop hate watching it?
Because I also hate watched it.
I was part of the problem.
I was also part of the problem.
but the fucking animation quality was so good the writing
was fucking terrible of course but like oh my god the
fucking the okay by the way not only did i guys i need you
all to stop hate watching felma because i already hate watch
season two and i need you guys to stop because i already did
my part and i need you guys to be stronger than me.
I need you.
I need you all to be stronger than me.
Like, it's not just me.
That's why I want you guys to be stronger.
Okay, no, I'll tell you the story.
I'll tell you the story of Alma.
I'll tell you season two.
Okay, Scrappy Do comes back in season two.
And I swear to God, I need this guy to stop being in every
animated show.
Not Scrappy Do, but the guy who fucking voices Scrappy Do.
So who voices Scrappy Do?
Okay, it is.
I need a fucking...
Okay, I need to like look up his name because I never
remember his name.
But his fucking voice is so iconic.
So the person is Jason Menzuka's.
And you guys are like...
Who's that?
He has been in every fucking animated show lately because
his voice is so recognizable, but he only voices as himself.
He only plays himself.
I swear to God, he has been typecasted as himself.
Every time.
It's some, okay, not himself, but like some fucking crazy
dude.
It's always some fucking crazy dude.
He's in everything now.
And I'm tired.
Like he has a great voice.
But I'm fucking tired of hearing him right now.
I'm fucking tired of hearing him in every animated show I'm
watching.
It's just, because he just plays the same guy.
Anyway, he's scrappy-doo, by the way.
He's, uh, uh, he's, he plays as a scrappy-doo.
And let me tell you the whole story.
Okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna tell you season two of Velma.
watch velma like i i did it for you chat i fucking i hate
watch velma so you don't have to hate watch velma so we
won't give velma season three uh so so the thing is okay the
thing is uh so shaggy who is it norm norville okay by the
way shaggy isn't called shaggy anymore he's called norville
but the and so like norville starts like in season one he
doesn't eat anything it's it's not shaggy like in season one
like he doesn't eat anything he doesn't like snack at all he
like he still wears his like green shirt or whatever but he
doesn't have a dog or anything and he doesn't you know he we
all know shaggy was you know like like woo molly you know
okay so um um norville does not do any of that and in season
two he starts having like hallucinations and like he starts
having hallucinations and like starts getting triggered by
um by like uh by because he killed fred's mom so he keeps
having hallucinations and like triggered hallucinations and
like trauma and stuff and the only way to stop his
hallucination is to eat so that throughout the He, he snacks
and eats a lot because he wants to stop the hallucinations.
What would you think of the 10 gift of chips?
Thank you.
He's like, the only way to stop my hallucination is if I
snack on something.
Quick Velma, give me a snack.
Like, and then, and, um, yeah, he kills friends.
Yeah, he kills friends.
mom so he has like hallucinations but don't worry Fred's mom
was a bad person anyway the hex sisters are back but they're
old the hex sisters has a cameo by being like uh by being
like uh like like roommates with Daphne's parents um and um
and so like one of that it's like one of the hex sisters and
then like she has a child she's like old the hex sister is
old now it's one hex sister by the way it's one hex sister
and she's our mom now and she has a child who's a teenager
who go who are staying over at Daphne's place uh because
they're broke or something because they're open a witch
store anyway none of that is important the whole plot is
some fucking brain switching plot because Norville's fucking
grandmother is a scientist who was working on a thing called
Project Scooby and you're like what's Project Scooby Scooby.
What Project Scooby is like the brain swapping operation
thing.
So he like they Norville found out that his grandmother
never died and she was actually hiding out in the facility
where where she helps soldiers and helps people find the
true self by swapping their brains into a jar so they can
find themselves and they're like when they are when they are
in a jar when they're a brain in a jar um they realize what
they want to be in the future because they're like you know
they're they're just a brain in the jar so they can like uh
figure out what's their purpose in life and after they
figure out their purpose in life she swaps the brain back
into that purse body so that's what project scooby is but
then there is a hidden person called uncle scooby and people
are trying to figure out who is the secret identity of uncle
scooby and the thing about that is that they created, Uncle
Scooby and the military created a project using the research
from Norville's grandmother to make scrappy do.
And scrappy do is like a fucking murderer.
Like, because, and the story starts off.
Let me just say, the story starts off in season two where
there has and now then they were wondering who committed
these murders and so they were trying to figure out who the
fuck committed all these murders and then later on they
found out that they that these people died by having their
dicks bit off so
some people were like oh my god all these middle-aged men
are getting our dick spit off what's going on and we
discovered it was scrappy dude this entire time
so um um um first person thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you thank you do anything for you to stop anything
you know what did you so anyway um anyway the ending of the
story is that everyone tries to stop scrappy dude from
fucking biting their tics
pay for my silence so people are trying to fucking um people
are trying to figure out like how to stop scrappy do from
killing everybody and it ends i'll just skip to the ending
chat and it basically ends where scrappy um where velma
sacrifices her life uh to to help stop scrappy do from
killing everybody and then she possesses and then scrappy do
and then like a fucking missile oh yeah the military sends a
missile at the school uh and and it hits scrappy do but
scrappy do survives but uh velma doesn't survive and then
scrappy do was like get ready to kill the rest of the the
rest of the gang and then he got possessed and died of a
heart attack i don't fucking know how he actually died it
just showed him getting possessed and then we found out
Velma becomes a ghost and ghosts are real
like people were like oh my god wait ghosts are real and
then um and then this the the season ends with a fact that
uh the season ends with them being like what do we do and
Velma Velma was like do I go to the light or do I stay here
and try to figure things out and and then the the heck
sister like daughter was like don't worry Velma I know a way
to get your body back and but I will need a study for we got
to wait until the summer so I need to study all these witch
books to figure out how to get your body back Velma and then
the show ends That was the end of season two
Look, I actually, like, took out all the fucking filler in
between So you're welcome, guys Because there was a lot of
things going on in between every Because, like, there was
one where Velma's mom gets together with Fred's dad And then
Velma's dad dad's new wife, like Velma's stepmom got
together, like Velma's stepmom was actually Uncle Scooby
this entire time, who was working behind the scenes
undercover as a waitress and like purposely tried to like
get close to Velma's dad so that she could get more
information regarding like Regarding Project Scooby.
Like...
Anyway, Mercy, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Can we never speak of Velma again?
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
And then thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My brain hurts.
Anyway, now you guys don't have to watch Velma Season 2.
Because all you need to know is that Scrappy Do is in it.
And he was biting.
Like, who, the first episode is, like, who are the murders?
It was Scrappy Do.
He was the one that bit everybody's dick off.
Anyway.
Also.
Also, by the way.
Oh, yeah.
Velma and Daphne are dating, too.
I don't know if that's relevant.
And Norville's dating a fucking brain.
And then Fred is just...
very stupid like i don't he has like mommy and daddy issues
uh
um wait thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you this
is my second time listening to your stream how how this
evolved into velma season two i don't know all i know is
that i am playing a train simply simulator chuckling my ass
off about how badly ridden velma is i think i'll stay with
ghosts in a shell standalone complex thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you um anyway that was velma season
two and after all of that i will have this okay to be fair
okay i have a confession i watched episode one to five of
season two and that skipped to the last episode because i
was like because it was there was no progression i swear the
progression of the of season two was like 99% filler and
then 1% of the actual plot so I was like who the fuck is the
murderer I was so I swear to God I I couldn't like I was
just like who the fuck is the murderer I was just where
where every time it's just a filler episode I swear it was
like we make 1% progress of the fucking show plot and then
everything else was like Fred has mommy issues How is he
gonna solve that and like um, and Norville suddenly has no
empathy, but don't worry He's just gonna get it back in like
the next episode or something.
I'm like, where's the progression?
I just I just want to know who the fuck is the murderer
that's biting off people's dicks.
Who is it?
It's like at first you're like Oh somebody's chopping off
their dicks And I was like oh my god who the fuck is killing
people by chopping off their dicks And then later on we find
out that scrappy dude fucking eating it And I'm like what
the fuck and I got shown that in the last episode Like I
didn't find that out until the last episode where I just
skipped to the final episode To figure out what the fuck is
going on like
I need to take a break dookie.
I'm sorry This is too much Anyway Despite all of that I hate
how good the animation is Like the quality of the visuals
For Velma Is too good for what the show is about And it
hurts It actually is not fair It's not fair at all Why is
the quality so good
There was like moments in there where I was like, wow, the
animation and the face animation and the visuals and the and
there were moments where they do like insane shading and
like expressions and everything.
And I'm like, why does this look so good?
But why does this look so fucking good for the show I'm
watching?
Anyway, I hate watch that show, so you don't have to.
Please do not give, please do not give Velma another hate
watch.
I beg of you.
It does not deserve a season three.
I swear to God.
I know you guys are like now super curious, but I swear to
God, it was, it, it, it sounds better than what it actually
is.
Like, Scooby's not even in it, guys.
Scooby-Doo isn't even in it, chat.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway, there was, that was, I can't believe I said majority
of this chatting stream today.
Just talking about animation.
I was just incredibly passionate, chat.
I was, I was so fucking passionate.
Jumping on to another topic, what the fuck is Tarkov doing?
doing did you guys hear about it i didn't like i never like
joined uh i never played tarca um but like um for those who
don't know uh for those who don't know tarcaf like basically
like a little i guess like um speed run of what's going on
right now tarcaf basically tried to release a game that was
like 200 plus dollars and people were like what the fuck
it's like this paid away oh yeah and it's like paid a win
dlc and it basically sort of killed tarcoff at the moment
but like not fully because i was talking to one of my
friends and i was because like they love tarcoff and i was
like yo and then they were like i don't know what to play
and then i was like what do you want playing and they're
like i'm gonna play tarcoff i was like what the fuck
they're like uh what do you mean why are you playing didn't
like didn't like shit happen why are you playing tarcoff and
then my friend was like my friend he was like oh it was on
sale because of all that drama
it was like it was like oh yeah you know like after
everything they put it on sale and i was like i couldn't
miss the opportunity like
yeah it was i think it was like 50 or something because he
was like oh yeah i don't know when it's gonna be like 50
again i might as well like buy buy the dip
yeah because because of everything that's going on at the
moment Tarkov decided to do like a huge fucking sale to like
convince people that they're they're like thinking about the
consumers now and they're like think like they're like sorry
for the mistake we made uh but we're gonna uh gaming
marketing is so it is it is I talked about this before
because don't matter how much like Nintendo does you the
moment they release a new legend of zelda you guys would
just eat that shit up it doesn't matter what they do like
the gaming audience is so easy to manipulate like like did
you guys heard about about like uh get the gary's mod shit
like do you guys you sell that where where like it's like
okay the new the new the gary's mod thing where They're they
don't we don't know if it's like actually nintendo like
people don't know for sure yet But basically the whole gist
is that nintendo filed like copyright takedowns on uh on uh
gary's mod and um So gary's mod now has to take down like 20
years worth of nintendo ip stuff in in gary's mod and that's
20 years It was so sad that gary's the devs of gary's mod
was like It would help so much if you guys could take it
down yourself because there's 20 years of There's like
there's 20 years of content and it's so much to do
And And They're like please and just don't re-upload it And
like the Viking desert like please take it down for us
it's not the first time and it's not going to be the last
and like the moment they release something oh my gosh and
then nintendo's gonna be like guys we're gonna make a legend
of zelda movie and you guys would just forget yes yes you
guys would be like next nintendo direct oh my god um
nintendo
yes you guys gamers you're just so easy to fucking like
we're very simple-minded I I'm simple-minded I would know
that's weird that's what I'm saying it's there's just so
simple-minded that would be like oh my god fucking 80% off
of Tarkov might as well like we don't know when that's gonna
happen again it just sucks because like Tarkov is like one
of the only it's only if somebody makes a better better
Tarkov-esque game because like every time somebody tries to
do like a um a version of Tarkov it dies like who is that
one the one with the space one the cycle the cycle died so
fast oh my god I can't believe I spent
yeah 80% off $250 what a fucking steal
um yeah cycle frontiers dark blade thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you spider rotors don't forget yes but
they're still playing smash though do you really never
forget if you're still trying to like play smash brothers
and also trying to try to set up tournaments despite like uh
despite like everything that Nintendo tries to do against it
like like if you never forget you just leave but smash
brothers don't leave they stay it's just torture at that
point like they're so good yeah
um kaz thank you the super chat thank you thank you like i
still buy pokemon plushies i still love pokemon i'm still
gonna like i know my place stop it hurts they're in their
own little purgatory we're all part of the problem what dark
plane what other games can we play oh my god that's so it's
so sad
what other games do we play the donkey
what i'm saying it doesn't matter wait there's nothing we
can do
actually sad oh my god oh that was that was i think i think
i'm gonna call it here guys i think i'm gonna call it here
chat i had i had a great time hanging out with you guys
today dragons it was a nice Nice good night dragoons radio
session today that we had and obviously I always enjoy just
hanging out with you guys and just like talking sad ending
I'm saying I love okay oh my gosh but did you guys see uh
did you guys see okay I'm trying to think of something
positive to say
Oh my god, Doki Amber Doge was so cute today guys.
I'm gonna pause it.
Doki Amber Doge was so cute today guys um because like um uh
today today he keeps like dropping off like little little
like toys and stuff every time like I let him up on my bed
to like uh sleep with me and he always like just like brings
a toy over over it brings a toy over and now like I realized
there's Like a whole stash of like toys is toys and stuff at
the end of my bed It's so fucking cute.
Anyway.
Oh yes, the convention if you guys didn't know If you guys
didn't know I'm going to be at anime north.
It's actually my very very first Canadian convention Like
I've never it's actually crazy as a Canadian Canadian bird
I've never been to a can I never guessed guessed it at a
Canadian convention before I was really excited to have this
opportunity.
I'll only be there for a panel for one day.
It's going to be like 8.30 p.m.
ESC Eastern because Anime North is on East Coast.
But I'm going to be doing a Q&A panel for an hour on Friday,
I believe.
So it is in Canada.
It's in Canada.
And it's going to be the first convention for my Doki World
Tour.
So there's going to be many more conventions in the future.
look forward to it uh so there's no meet and greet for this
one uh but that doesn't there's there wouldn't be meet and
greets in the future for the other conventions um a huge
shout out for anime north because like they actually like
fit me in last minute um uh because i saw their request a
little bit late and they fit me in last minute so they
weren't able to set up like meeting greets and stuff due to
how last minute it was uh so yes i think i like asked if i
could Like, they, like, requested for me, like, they, like,
requested for me a while back, and then I saw the email for
it.
Like, we, like, me and my team saw the email for it last
month, because it got lost.
So I was like, oh, I really want to start, I really want to
do a convention in May.
And then we, like, and we were able to get in last minute
for a, for a panel with them.
So I'm super excited.
Anyway, I'll see you guys there.
anime north.
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, pause,
check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, stay up for me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Also, I know I said next week there was going to be two
collabs.
It's going to be one collab because the other one got
rescheduled.
It was supposed to be a singing lessons with Yusun next
week, but then we had like conflict of schedules between the
two of us.
So, um, we decided to reschedule that to, um, two weeks
later.
I don't remember the exact date, but, like, uh, that's why
it's going to be one, one collab next week instead.
So, next time, two.
So, just look forward to that other collab soon-ish.
I think it's going to be, like, in two weeks or something.
Anyway, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!